[Musique]
mayroy jeu
oui moi
bah
mais
quoi
pour les eaux
wade
moi
attention car le jeune ayew toi et toi
retourne cuidado éloignez les enfants
des prises de courant éloigner les plus
grands des postes de télé voici lunettes
noires pour nuits blanches
l'émission qui vous électrocute c'est en
fer à repasser que je voudrais me
réincarner c'est la guerche aux
questions qu'on voit louve a percé d'une
autre histoire
stone et charden dans lunettes c'est
encore plus fort la tête trompait avec
chamfort rifaat cloud c'est à dire chou
préfabriqués rien à voir avec les
occasions décérébrés 100% pur sang
spécial cannibale quand ils ont la dalle
on se fait la malle régime de faveur
avec notre régiment de bananarama érudit
rencontre rtl marc toesca le petit coup
en français par aiguë zerg août exclu ni
dan reed l'art phelim de portland qui
fait trembler le nain de minneapolis les
résultats de l' enquête de globe sur les
intégristes par ce qui en fait oui papa
games rappeur la musique que vous
entendez c'était l'an prochain tube
c'est nous
le rock c'est aussi de la future cette
semaine
moi si jeanne que j'aime a manqué le
match il est du fond du pont de la fin
tout est bon night club il accroît est
une flotte et dans l'arène des
collections une fois de plus que c'est
le petit taureau qu'à gagner et voilà
sommerville que toute la presse anglaise
surnomme tronche de patates un petit
pouce l'express sur le zinc pour le beau
ranger
remettez - saint patron avec un bon
blind test voici lunettes noires pour
nuits blanches l'émission zappant tout
seul
chivu venge des autres
richard bohringer bonsoir bonnes années
on peut encore dire bonne année là ouais
bonne santé de bonne santé alors 88
c'était plutôt une bonne année pour toi
parce que tu nous as fait un best seller
et un césar pour thann a vendu combien
de c'est beau une ville la nuit
proxi aux alentours 300 mm ouais tu vas
en faire
ah ouais ouais maintenant que j'ai
retrouvé les questions je vais pas
laisser tomber sur les tares fait un
film avec jean loup hubert qui t'a valu
ton celui qu'il avait du temps aux césar
ouais vous surfez un film qui s'appelle
après la guerre avec moi les enfants qui
sort quand qui vont sortir au mois de
mai là tu pars faire un film avec green
ah ouais c'est de plus en plus fort sur
café le ventre de l'architecte c'est
quoi l'histoire c'est l'histoire d'un
chef cuisinier cannibale rihanna qui
sort début février n'arrête mois qui
s'appelle la soul
on va d'abord pour bien expliquer en
d'abord parler du jeu de la soul parce
que les gens savent pas obligatoirement
ce que c'est c'est un peu l'ancêtre du
foot l'ancêtre du rugby c'est un jeu
très violent un jeu très violent très
physique
c'est un jeu qui pourrait ressembler au
rugby mais il n'y a pas de règle les
règles c'est l'espace ça veut dire c'est
toute la campagne et toute la région le
courir 50 km il faut porter la solde
d'un village à l'autre tous les coups
sont permis d'ailleurs c'est un jeu qui
permettait au village participant à ce
jeu là de régler des comptes
le jour de la soul on pouvait tuer son
ennemi
bonjour la soul on pourrait tous les ans
c'est l'histoire d'un militaire pendant
là ça se passe autant de après la chute
de napoléon ça se passe commande le
respect restauration et c'est l'histoire
d'un militaire qui trahi par un autre et
la bataille des visites à rien espagne
et qu'il le retrouve après quoi il y
retrouve le mât qui l'a trahie qu'est
devenu cordonnier dans un village c'est
toi voilà le mec c'est malavoy et tous
les deux vous participez à la soul dans
des équipes concurrentes et puis le mec
veut tuer en gros c'est ça mais ça veut
dire que moi j'ai eu peur j'ai eu peur
j'ai eu peur de la mort autour de moi
j'ai eu peur de tout ça je me suis barré
avec un strap
et puis lui n'a de cesse lorsqu'il va
être libéré parce qu'il a été fait
prisonnier de cesse que de me retrouver
et il me retrouvera dans un petit
village où on joue à la soul est il lui
aussi va participer à l'assaut une façon
détournée de régler ses comptes avec moi
il ya une femme qui essaie de vous
réconcilier qui est ce la main qui
essayent devrait concilier tous les deux
parce qu'elles prennent même pas la
guerre comme toutes les femmes projet
fibre pour moi j'étais très et puis et
puis il y avait une chose aussi dans ce
scénario de dans la façon dont michel
sibra a voulu que le film se fasse ça
veut dire que au fur et à mesure qui m'a
lancé des noms pour jouer les autres
rôles
c'étaient tous des potes normal que ce
soit jean pierre sentiers que ces
soignants roland blanche qu'un que tu
adores qu'on adore tous est un grand
acteur
mon frère quoi et puis à mon cousin
stephen il ya mon autre sentier puis à
mon pote malavoy jédir sa part est
toujours bizarre de dire mes potes mes
potes
bah oui bah c'est mes potes et dans la
dans la vie c'est mes potes parce que en
dehors du métier d'acteur c'est des gens
avec qui j'aime bien déchirer l'année un
petit peu avec qui j'aime bien refaire
le monde qui j'aime bien échanger mes
doutes et puis mes joies koala en 88 et
quand même deux films que tu as fait
qu'on pas trop marché faut bien le dire
quoi ca da dans la jungle et puis à
gauche en sortant de l'ascenseur je
crois pas que tu as fait un peu trop des
films de temps en temps
non non non moi je pense pas que je fais
trop de fils je pense qu'avant de films
ont sept ans
mais sur les trente films j'ai fait des
films qu'on a fait avec des cacahuètes
dans le fin fond de de la cordillère des
andes et des films à des initiatives
comme ça c'est les films apparence et
ceux qui ont été le plus ça finisse
comme ça
ben j'ai eu des échecs mais je sais pas
j'ai l'impression que les échecs moi ça
me va ça me donne une pêche d'enfer
j'ai de toute façon je fais les choses
avec à manger pas soit c'est vrai que tu
reçois un scénario par jour ouais je
n'arrive pas à dire non des fois y'a des
fois à l'affectivité prend le pas sur le
reste un jeu c'est très par les films
mais c'est vrai qu'il ya des fois genou
et puis je regrette pas d avoir fait
même si les films sont pas abouti même
si les filles ne sont pas parce que j'en
attendais pas je regrette jamais les
avoir fait tu fais beaucoup de premiers
films
ouais tu sais ce qu'elle a dit sandrine
bonnaire quand même oui et j'en ai marre
de faire des premiers films c'est
toujours raté il faut bien les faire les
premiers fille est quelqu'un d face il
faut bien que quelqu'un le fasse et puis
moi je connais des metteurs en scène qui
en ont déjà 15 derrière eux et qu'il ira
toujours
donc voilà richard tu as entendu parler
du questionnaire de proust vrai et en
fait n'est pas de proust rentrer à moins
que tout le monde croit c'est un jeu de
société français qui date de l'époque de
napoléon iii
il tord après un truc oui c'est fou ce
qu'on apprend comme truc dans cette
énigme mais c'est chaud c'est chaud
pour quelle faute à tu le plus
d'indulgence la peur temps pas trop
favori charles mathon ton pote joël
gigue et a trouvé en plus ce qui t'a
fait faire ton premier film charles
mathon ouais mais si mon maître
spirituel c'est moi c'est mon ami c'est
mon père c'est plein de choses comme ça
mais bon la question c'était mon pote
favori n'entend pas trompé moi il
charles-mathon ouais ouais
charles-mathon charles-mathon vertus
préféré vertus vertu je suis parce que
c'est avec la vertu ton occupation
préférée la vie le principal trait de
caractère emmerdeur tampon est favori
rené char c'est le même que jacques
chirac
sauf que toi tu as peut-être l'urne non
mais je pense qu'il n'a lui il veut pas
je ne peux pas nana je pense qu'il a lu
et puis même si on n'est pas d'accord
sur certaines choses ont fait une
incursion de plein fouet
bien sûr sur la poésie ça rapproche les
hommes s'il aime les charges
rien n'est perdu ouais ce que tu déteste
par dessus tout j'ai tellement de
défauts que tu peux pas reprocher grand
chose à reprocher c'est alors le défaut
que j'aime le moins quoi ouais les trucs
que tu peux pas saquer quand même chez
les gens truc il gonfle à mort je
croyais jusqu'il ya quelques années je
croyais que la frime
c'était un prix qui m'était
insupportable et puis je me suis aperçu
que la frime ça pouvait être aussi la
façon que les êtres est de vivre des
rêves
- même s'ils sont futiles et même s'ils
sont alors je roule défaut ce serait
quoi
ce que tu supportes pas ben ça veut dire
si je prêt de 10,5 pas de téléphone pas
pour me dire je peux reprendre les
rendre voilà maintenant que tu es riche
tempête beaucoup de l'argent je suis pas
tout vote avant 330 mille exemplaires
d'un bouquin on n'est pas pauvre
maintenant à nous on n'est pas pauvre ça
par rapport à un mec qui gagne 5000
balle par mois c'est sûr qu'on est pas
pour par rapport aux mecs de pecchi
n'était pas riche riche riche passé sur
[Musique]
l'avenir de mes espérances espoirs
teigne de 10 ouais je vais pas toujours
mises en pratique toujours mise en
pratique j'aimerais ne pas être un
fidèle à moi même
[Musique]
l'ifab sprites à venir chou préfabriqués
rien à voir avec neo cohésion décérébrés
chouchou de la critique en 88 avec son
blog libor toman fif
le leader du groupe palima kanoun
souvent comparé à elvis costello joe
jackson est un songwriter de tout
premier ordre
et si tu fermes ta gueule on pourrait
écouter la musique
king avocat noir normand
c'est une équipe aux commandes
[Musique]
m
non
quoi
[Musique]
zhang
x
qui
[Musique]
b
je m'excuse
ford veut jouer
et
[Musique]
ça va
qui
comment
cela
je ne parle pas
non
besson
morales né
en effet mme daka
avec l'espoir que vous
[Musique]
la quinzaine à marquer ne voit que lui
suite
[Musique]
je n'ai pas
jean
eh oui
banquier
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
et maintenant voici la queen et aylwin
vous le saurez après ce léger panneaux
de francis ford colonna sur un tableau
de claude guingamp mesdames messieurs
dans leur caisse je pars une semaine en
vacances à l'époque des fêtes juste
avant les fêtes
je reviens tu as fait un scandale encore
couronne d'épinés chili progressé sur
tmc
ses pattes refusé par la cncl tu verras
c'est fini les salisiennes oui son pull
à son plus bas ils sont partis on est
content on en a d'autres non
est ce que les nouveaux vont être aussi
imbécile vous pensez pas bon ce débat
c'est le grand mystère
côté catholique pourtant non il paraît
oui on mettait catholique pourquoi les
catholiques je suis quatre pays la
couronne d'épinés ça ne choque pas non
c'est la mienne de toute façon je te
signale que pas bon quand on lui avait
laissé faire et où elle est elle
m'appartient toile à moi je dirais pas
piquer la couronne à quelqu'un ouais
c'est ta couronne oui oui
alors dis moi ton disque avait été
classé dans le top européen
donc tu en profite pour faire une
tournée européenne oui ça se passe
comment satisfaire cette histoire ça
passe par l'allemagne ça passe par la
hollande savas par l'italie sa basse par
l'espagne ça fasse par la russie ouais
mais c'est surtout ben oui et puis ça va
passer par paris quand même et puis par
la france parce que tu as entendu parler
des questions cons alors oui oui oui
j'ai enfin parler
[Musique]
si tu avais le choix pour faire l'amour
bien entendu entre une fille très très
très jolie ou un mec très laid tu
choisirais quoi mais il faut répondre
oui ou non comme ça dépend de la fille
jeudi où le mec là est peut-être qu'il
est très intelligent donc après avoir dû
prendre alors oui parce que pas vraiment
film
non mais c'est vrai a déclaré d'ailleurs
une fois je me souviens on dit toujours
que j'aime les femmes et les fous et en
fait je fais des cas là à mon jules oui
oui oui
non je lui rendrai le mac les quoi a
priori oui a priori le mac mais voilà
définitif oui oui alors imagine que ton
mec t'es pas touché pendant quinze jours
malgré des remarques persistante
tu l'as fait sentir que effectivement
pourrait s'intéresser un peu à toi
qu'est-ce que tu ferais tu regardes ton
carnet de téléphone en dix ans cherchant
à un autre mec tu te jette sur lui comme
ça violemment un soir dans la salle de
bain pendant qu'il se lave les dents
dans sa robe de chambre
ou alors vous alors tu engages à
détective privé pour savoir avec qui tu
vas être coûteux refaire dans l'ordre
alors alors je vais jette sur lui
d'abord d'abord ahmed accords du jazz
mais comment ça se passerait pas atteint
je sais pas j'ai enfin cette idée mais
je serais parti se lave les dents par
exemple c'est à dire que oui je
profiterai l'a déjà une main occupée
l'autriche tient sur le bord du lac mais
on s'est discrètement bon dans le miroir
commencer par le baril majine que j'en
arrive à la troisième solution parce que
les deux premières n'ont pas marché ce
détective privé te dis
ah oui je suis désolé nous 30 madame
qu'est ce que tu fais est ce que tu lui
couperait le sexe avec une tronçonneuse
[Musique]
savez question pense que ça m'a permis
mais tu lui tranche le sexe avec une
hausse non tu perces le coeur avec une
perceuse
ça fait déjà plus forcément tu me tire
une balle dans la nuque comme un chien
mais non mais je dis qu'on est enragé 7
charme et la fille puis à la limite je
peux peut-être me faire pour une fois la
fille ah tu reviens sur ce que tu as dit
que tu as oui mais ça dépend des
circonstances marsan si tu te fais la
fiba pourquoi pas enfin j'essaye les
rapports tu sais que antennes de la
direction d'antenne
on n'est jamais censuré sauf qu un
certain nombre de remarques pour lui
tirer pour votre addiction très bien
tout ça mais il faut arrêter de parler
de nécrophilie à l'antenne c'est un truc
bon alors on va parler de zoophilie
parce que ça et me l'ont pas dit très
bien c'est bien oui alors tu as le choix
nous obligés de faire l'amour avec un
animal obligé t'as pas le choix qui dira
c'est comme ça est-ce que tu avec un
chien car la brade ses jolies des
labradors annoncé le labrador terme
c'est un jeu est-ce que tu préférais le
labrador de giscard au labrador de
mitterrand j'ai deux réponses n'ont pas
jamais le jamais le labrador à xian a
chanté pour le clip sur l'arménie parce
que tellement de gens je sais pas si je
t'écoute c'est très gentil mais
on en a parlé c'est ça s'est arrêté là
leur avance j'aurais pas dit non mais
doit y avoir un truc et agatha qui s'en
occupent les arméniens ils sont plus
tourne-disque non et puis toute façon on
peut très bien participer c'est comme
les éthiopiens ils entendent jamais ce
qu'on fait pour eux imaginez maintenant
que tu es plein de thunes plein de
thunes est-ce que tu préfèrerais donner
ton argent aux pauvres arménien oppose
ethiopia ça c'est toujours une âme à
cette question de quoi on sait qu'il ya
pas de réponse
question il faut vraiment répondre leur
beau jeu les pauvres armenia qui sont
sous les décombres file encore qu'ils
sont vivants paraît-il où les pauvres
éthiopien cambrai la mort je sais c'est
dur c'est naturel voiture moi j'en
envoie des tous les côtés non non c'est
non j'ai pas non non ça marche pas les
arméniens nous étions elle demande à son
groupe
alors voilà une réponse
bah oui tu vois je alors maintenant est
ce que tu préfères le maillot un sperme
et c'est très très con est ce que tu
préférais mourir comme john lennon parle
de mort de star m'a séduit et là tu
préfères nombreux
est-ce que tu préférais mourir comme
john lennon c'est à dire une balle dans
le ventre
toi est ce que tu pourrais me faire
mourir comme janis joplin d'une overdose
ou comme le chanteur décide ici est mort
le policier tout fait dans son vomi dit
tu préfères la balme en grand
bon bah écoute avis aux amateurs
tu es morte ah bon comme je les donne
mais tu as vu il ya une émission sublime
sur la mort après ben oui après on vit
pas la façon c'est un problème voilà
alors est ce que maintenant tu vas être
réincarné bon tu crois la réincarnation
jeu dès samedi croyons vous pourrez y
ont dit deux minutes
est-ce que tu préférais être réincarné
en fer à repasser en pechiney laver ou
un aspirateur été obligé de répondre
c'est pas possible
ah non non non non la chapelaine moi
j'ai lu le bouquin il ya neuf ans non
non non non ça c'est pas possible en
faire un passé qui suit m'a dit
inspirateur machine à laver tout
simplement en fer à repasser
tu préfères faire oui parce que ça fait
des caresses aux gens d'abord parce que
ça peut être doux et ça peut être une
vraie sarah pourtant dans les comptes il
aspirait conneries toute la journée
l'eau qui l'avait quadri des mois voilà
donc le faire à faire passer l'un
imagine deux minutes que tu prends mes
fautes aujourd'hui magique c'est un jeu
parmi les imagine sa machine que tu
prends bon qu'est-ce que tu reprocherait
le plus à dessus tout allons-y tout
prenant des exemples précis
est ce que tu veux reprocherait d'avoir
mis au monde finalement
rika zaraï zinta des sousa ah oui marie
france cuba d'art qui est pas mal non
plus je te la conseil était obligé la
normale à tout le monde
non mais c'est des questions auxquelles
tout le monde répond serait pas beau
tout le monde répond alors je répète
marie france cuba da linda de suza rika
zaraï qu'est ce que tu reproches de plus
au bon dieu d'avoir mis sur terre non
mais non mais je ne reproche pas ça se
rapproche des trucs bien pire que sa
voiture est grave at on vraiment à
l'étroit que je suis jeune mais c'est
pas n'importe quoi je les ai choisi
exprès
ah là là mais c'est emmerdant des
troubles semblables sont bien surtout
quand d'un seul coup les trois tu ferais
peut-être un blue tu vois j'en sais rien
étudiant proche des 3 ans blog en bas
bowie temps qatar mais sur terre les
trois bas voilà comme ça qu'est ce que
tu fais pas de jalouse là tu fais pas de
gel sont à l'étroit dans le même sac
mais alors imaginons maintenant que tu
survol d'angleterre en avion
bon bien sûr tu en conviendras les deux
moteurs les moteurs sont en feu l'avion
va tomber parce que tout avion survolant
angleterre c'est un patient à les deux
moteurs ont fait bien l'affairé c'est la
mode
c'est là qu'on voit qu'il a inventé ça
est tous d'accord donc tendance que
jamais du coup vous êtes trois dans
l'avion seulement oui il ya deux
parachutes
alors bon tampon à bon bah oui non mais
attends qui sait les deux autres trucs
est riche en sel non pas dire au caire
et plus près tu mens avant d'accord donc
tu donnes les parachutes à drucker tout
tu fais bien les parachutages pas à
contrecoeur mais tu fais bien ton
business et du film et parachutes aux
gens qui ont des émissions de télé
qu'est ce que tu veux non mais c'est
bien quand tu fais tu prennes ton cou
enfin c'est plutôt de rigueur quand même
tu choisis le mec à 20h30 tous les
samedis non mais c'est pas non ce n'est
pas un roman mais non c'est pas une
histoire de 20h30 c'était plutôt une
histoire d'argent
non bon alors c'est bon les passants ou
alors maintenant dernière question c'est
une tradition si tu veux dans cette
émission c'est le vaisseau spatial tu
dois partir dans un vaisseau spatial bon
parce que c'est une histoire qui dure
d'émission en émission
il va partir dans un vaisseau spatial et
tu peux choisir sur ces quatre ans le
saut spécial c'est pas de la rigolade
ces quatre ans que la même personne
encore un couteau servir à rien en
apesanteur pendant quatre ans avec la
même personne paraît qu'après les
muscles ah oui tu vas voir derrière toi
équité 1 est ce que tu préfères partir
attention on décolle avec france gall
lara catherine lara wii ou véronique
sanson à 7,3 mais oui c'est un jeu irak
et l monopoly c'est la rue de la paix
depuis des siècles je veux dire tu dois
en choisir une des trois et on est que
toutes les deux pendant quatre ans la
pesanteur je te souhaite bien des
catholiques c'est que toutes les deux
laquelle tu choisis mais lara ce n'est
pas parce que c'est ensemble a choisi la
raho si l'état tu vois bien n'a dit
qu'elle prendra un petit maillot mais je
sais où enfin bon toi tu couteau comme
ton couteau et ben tu vois j'ai été bon
mais moi je crois que je suis pas
forcément complètement quand c'est mieux
quelques acquis au roi un peu
d'apprentissage mais voilà lancés à leur
jambon la france a priori non
non dont catherine la wii des gens
d'expérience et en large
ban à mana mana rama 14 union numéros
entre 82 et 88
c'est encore plus foie de volaille que
les suprêmes dans la formation actuelle
la brune jackie o sullivan a remplacé la
blonde siobhan pour vous interpréter
nasa jones et que si tu continues à
parler sur les clips
moi je payerai plus jamais ni marne à
nîmes et contredanses tu donnes ce matin
je t'aime quand même vous maintenant
[Musique]
tous
à
les jo
[Applaudissements]
départ demain
ça
tiens
[Musique]
m
oh
[Musique]
les jo
c'est vrai
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
à
m
bananarama vous avez vu les fruits en
surimpression c'est de la télé haute
définition est maintenant dans le genre
haute fidélité vous allez voir eric et
annie stone et charden le mans des
règlements des bleus mais c'est toujours
la 20e tour à après niagara et mitsouko
voici un nouveau store histoire c'est
une question conne mais toi par exemple
sans moi moi personnellement je pense
que je ferais pareil c'est à dire je
ferai
sûrement la chanteuse parce que je sais
rien faire d'autre vraiment alors bas
j'aurais peut-être trouvé
un autre compositeur pour faire mes
chansons bah je sais pas et puis c'est
pas sinon je vois vraiment pas ce que
j'aurais fait moquer des mecs sur la
liste ne s'arrête pas des compositeurs
si si même des compositeurs de deux
talents à des tanneries avec qui avait
concerné manon ses secrets ce nom
n'était pas vendu alain kouck non mais
des comme ça qui me plaisait alain
chamfort à bas coûts il est bien il est
resté quand même mon pianiste et et oui
en plus ses amis et chef d'orchestre
chez meurt comme ça lui est en baisse à
très très bon pied bon goût et bien
cette similitude à lui j'ai passé devant
chamfort comme tu vois c'est la seule
fois de ma vie je suis passé du temps
ils étaient deux ans sur scène mais
alors au point de départ as-tu déjà
repassés devant à quand j'étais seul oui
mais on était bon mais mais quand j'ai
été sage suis repassé devant ça me fait
plaisir car absolument sympa ça c'est
bien merci alain julian assange amène ta
poteau
question très simple qu'est-ce qui
tenait roues
qu'est ce qui m'énerve le plus chez moi
c'est très facile je trouve la réponse
trop sévit alors on s'arrête alors il
n'ya pas une autre
non mais je vais y répondre très bien la
réponse est pas non non non je sais il
ya une chose entre toutes
c'est la lâcheté oui c'est à dire
comment acheter
c'est finalement de temps en temps tu es
lâche toi que je sers a rebondi en
absolument tue c'est rarement dire non
et tu fuis en cas de problème
voilà je me cachais en bronze par
exemple une bonne idée alors là on s'est
retrouvé pour jeter tout donné entre
autres pour le disque sur le disque mais
est ce que tu crois qu'on va se
retrouver en duo un jour dans la vie
écoute je me souviens avoir dit des
trucs pour marc j'étais peut-être bourré
ça m'arrive assez sains et on va pas et
puis valorisés mais je crois qu'un jour
je t'avais dit peut-être qu on vieillira
ensemble oui alors comme je suis ni
madame soleil ni elizabeth teissier si
tu es capable de
de ne pas voir mais pourquoi pas alors
tu as dit une fois dans un journal je
suis un anarchiste
ça se traduit comment dans ta vie je
mettrais bien des bombes lanfains bros
comme j'ai pas envie qu'elle tue c'est
bon alors je dois faire rester et puis
de temps en temps lâcher des mots peu
plus ou moins mal au dos rond en fin
gourmet charge des mots quoi alors donc
après tout c'est come back toutes ces
équipes
est ce que cette fois c'est la bonne les
équipes sur et kg puis à nuit des temps
depuis que le soleil et puis que la
terre et la lune existe les éclipses
ça te fait quoi quand tu vois les
enfants que j'ai eus avec mario à tisser
je vais dire ça me fait ça me fait très
chaud qu'un parce que je trouve qui te
ressemble d'abord l'ong veut dire 300
pages pour mario sinon je tricote parce
que j'adore marionnettes c'est le
sélectionneur
mais je veux dire ils sont magnifiques
elles sont bon compte tout ils ont les
yeux de la maman
magie bleue c'est magique et quand je
les vois je me dis c'est con parce que
si j'étais resté avec elle peut être
qu'enfin le préfet une fille parce que
j'aime j'ai changé deux ou trois fois de
moules j'ai fait quand même que que les
mecs
est ce que tu crois sincèrement au fond
de toi l'intérieur là bas jusqu'en bas
les pattes qu'on a eu tort de se séparer
au nom voilà là qu'est ce qu'on a bien
fait génial non non on a très bien fait
elle avait bien des cas les deux noms
n'a pas eu tort d'abord pourquoi séparer
voilà c'est moi le sourire sourire voici
dan wind at work alias le réseau de
daniel roseaux l'orphelin de portland
qui fait trembler le nain de minneapolis
ghetto youth en eaux vives
l'hawaiien qui a quitté le 51e état où
il vendait des pom pom girls et qui
compte bien sur le rock'n'roll pour
devenir président des 50 autres manor je
t'aime que c'est pas possible
rock
[Musique]
catch
le mans
est paulo
[Musique]
yahoo
m
il
soula
tu veux parler
non
lequel
[Musique]
gargano
l'aïe
[Musique]
et
oui
m
[Musique]
messi
passé
m
[Musique]
kelly
là
la pop
[Musique]
et
il y a
ça
[Musique]
il
je me bats
dubois
[Musique]
hélas
aulas
[Musique]
l'eia
ghetto youth et aident à nourrir sans
une wii voici le beau ranger cas
tellement traîné rue saint-benoît qu'un
jour tous les biens qu'on lui fasse un
blind test spécial jazz au nom tout la
garrigue 8 en or comme tu as beaucoup
traîné rue saint benoît dans son jeune
temps on va faire un blindtest jazz
[Musique]
c'est le sait pas par contre c'est vrai
je vis this way
ça doit être lui
c'est un pianiste
[Musique]
justement
à temps
[Musique]
là
ap le
[Musique]
oh
trouver là ça pourrait être
et regardez où cette question avec un
qui s'appelle play misty for me j'ai pas
vu l'histoire d'un mec la radio comme
toi sur kiss et qui passent misty et
puis une bonne femme qui l'appelle comme
ça à chaque émission il passe mais ce
type c'est bien ça ne me dire que je
fais des radios sur qui ça fait mal
parce que j'adore faire de la radio et
je suis toute l'espagne mercredi soir
avec une équipe formidable c'est une
équipe formidable qui s'est fait
[Musique]
1958 à rome
m
c'est m ouais elle a well as
[Musique]
ab ça c'est dave brubeck
ouais le titre le titre c'est eux
airbus est un titre super simple super
ça y'a blue rondo à la turk il ya ça il
ya ça ça vient pas des fight night fall
se sont pas dit ouais ouais se lasser
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
oui mais alors la chine je connais bien
pour l'instant si un peu perdue là
j'attends un truc j'attends un truc
incident
[Musique]
c'est ses démons intérieurs de
cheesecake le bla bla s'il a bien connu
dexter g j'ai vécu avec les ouais il
n'était pas comme dans le film de
tavernier
il était c'est un des plus beaux mecs
que j'ai croisé ma vie un mètre 90 d'une
élégance incroyable j'étais tout mignon
un grand black magnifique avec un
sourire
fabuleux j'étais j'ai vécu dans un hôtel
rue saint benoît avec lui à l'hôtel
montana
[Musique]
ça c'est une très grosse versailles
c'est la plus grosse c'est très grosse
bête ca c
tu as passé ces tueries ouais c'est john
cage one way
aider oui
oui il faut absolument écouter la
musique jean louis st ouais
absolument il a écrit un blues qui fait
10 minutes
dans son dernier album qui s'appelle
s'en mêler ouais c'est un blues pour son
chien qui est mort c'est fantastique
[Musique]
on est en ce1 et les jours soit
premières lunettes noires de la semaine
guys and or si pour son concert au
palace les choletais aubin après son
concert à l'elysée montmartre alan vega
soûlé icas quart des 80 et sa fille
rouchy instar du 90 dans l'avenir tout
le monde sera célèbre moins cinq minutes
c'est ton tour ma vie elle a éliminé
vittel lance trail star de la vouivre
presse pierre le roch le monsieur cinéma
du rock'n'roll
[Musique]
marc toesca bonsoir bonsoir thierry
ardisson en europe 1 qui remonte c'est
grâce à ces mois de la photo en france
pas pourquoi parce que des trucs pareils
non parce qu'il faut être franc les
sondages pour l'instant c'est lundi
vendredi et - sauf ici le samedi de 9h30
à 11h puis le top 50 et puis le top 50
sur canal sur canal alors tu es l'auteur
d'un bouquin que je vais garder
d'ailleurs qui s'appelle ben ouais s'il
te plaît tant du championnat le guide du
tube je vais faire tous les érudits rock
avec ça maintenant et notre ami francis
dégustant l'applaudît de dominique
pharand pascal second c'est le mec qui
fait la chance ou pas bon donc c'est pas
moi je suis désolé à toi tu es un des
papas du rock sur rtl quoi quelque sorte
tu l'écris un peu en ce moment en europe
là bas je signale kertel out est
pratiquement donne mais c'est marrant
ces trucs de radio tout le monde remonte
à chaque fois tout le monde remonte
comme il descend cette fois ci on
saisonnière newey bombes dans des
cendres 7 mondial et vous êtes prêt là
vous avez vous savez à réviser je sais
pas on va essayer de faire fonctionner
les deux neurones qui nous reste un jeu
lors d'un train de pire quoi parce qu'on
va y aller avec talent au début c'est
chasse il s'échauffe mans
j'te jure par exemple blondy ouais
comment s'appelle la chanteuse que tout
le monde croit que ces blondes il se
change en france et c'est pas stone et
charden
non c'est peut-être des billards et
ouais tu vois que c'est facile
j'ai essayé c'est lui qui m'a piqué
dédié à ces mécaniques et le disque non
impliqués dans une fausse blonde les
flûtes enders la chanteuse christine
bravo
[Applaudissements]
maintenant on va faire les one hit
wonder ce qu'on fait un tube dans leur
dit si tu veux alors si je te dis je
vais te dire le nom du chanteur l'année
et tu vas me dire ce qu'il a fait si je
te dis bobby solo 64 jeunes à la crim a
soulevé ce brave aux candidats dessus
tout sourire on avait quatre enfants
flirter ensemble on a des enfants
je vais chanter d'ailleurs baisse est un
peu là-bas jours qu'on puisse jouer du
tambourin voilà on a une portée de
marcassin de pas tous mais la naissance
il tombe bien il en reste quelque chose
a dit jalal cinquetti même année nono
l'état ouais bon on en perd un peu plus
dur quand même la phase 4 on va faire
les chansons avec chou aichi chaussures
une chanson des beatles avec chou au
[__]
ouais mais l'époque des beatles était
qu'un projet ttp
ouais ouais c'est ça la vie joue avec
une chaussure d'épaves qui vont voler
harrison qui l'a écrit ah ouais c'est
dans 69 ans n'a pas équivoque war is
over justement c'est pour ça que ça peut
t'aider chouchane sous ce temps qu'est
ce qu'elle écrit
je crois pas que tu vas marquer la ceni
la marque et non l'âge aidant c'est vrai
que c'est toi que ça vient le salut les
p'tits clous pas ce qu'on peut appeler
marc toesca ouais non c'est non
seulement homme écrivait avec
mon nom sur les enveloppes c'était c'est
sidérant met et marc toesca marteau
comme tous les petits clos voulu sétois
l'inventeur des p'tits clous et c'est
important faut le dire il vraiment passé
les membres qui ont inventé marteau quoi
ouais ça c'est bien quand même bon je
sais pas à polémiquer à toulon faut
faire plus harrison nombre pas c'est sûr
qu'est ce qu'il à écrire comme de sun
qu'est ce qu'ils ont écrit
something a cédé all-bran chaud résumé
carl perkins avec shu soit chaud
voilà maintenant à faire beaucoup plus
dur
on va prendre deux chanteurs way dont le
prénom commence par un ace et le nom de
famille par un w alors on a commencé
avec toi un noir ah oui
stevie wonder boy raconte lui avec toi
en blanc steve winwood olala c'est pas
facile
stevie winwood et à banon mais bon là on
faire très très dur les groupes dans
lesquels a joué djordje harrison mais
déjà il a joué là et à vous demander à
chacun toi le dias et celui où il ya ya
ya john lennon
je te file combien base et les beatles
par exemple nord non alors ça ce serait
quand même des beatles a d'abord c'est
pas à voir les beatles avec john lennon
s'est pas laissée pas les silver beatles
et pas les voir y mène ouais c'est pas
ravi shankar family and friends c'est un
groupe où elle joue et harrison avec
lennon qui n'ait aucun des groupes que
je viens de te citer il y avait et
clapton y avait clôt ce format là oui ça
c'est déjà plus facile dahouët attendit
de pasqua c'est dingue mais c'est facile
à temps je suis troublant y avait daniel
bonnet c'est un super groupe et moi
c'est plastic ono band à l'héroïne alors
à toi maintenant un groupe mais je vais
djordje harrison où il y avait comme
betty au broyeur beeson lettres bingguo
squale a cette fois gagné excuse moi la
série mondiale
c'est comme un média maîtrise
encore une découverte de lunettes en
concert lundi à l'olympia sicile et
linda chez les du pendu pendu fin que
tout est bon ça s'étire de l'aps
[Musique]
faut écouter tout l'album à commencer
par ci libre est vivant après
ah ah
[Musique]
vote
je
marie
merci
[Musique]
m
et vite
[Musique]
à temps
je
m
[Musique]
ça
je
d
[Musique]
m
d
[Musique]
oh
je
[Musique]
m
dix ans
[Musique]
c'est
d
ok
[Musique]
m
s
ce mois-ci commencer votre tour de glad
par son voyage en intégrer le magazine
n'est pas encore dans les kiosques que
grunberg barbieux sont déjà dans
lunettes
serge greenberg et jean marc barr dieu
vous avez fait pour blob pour le numéro
qui sort en février une enquête qui
s'appelle voyage en intégrer suite à la
tacc du cinéma saint michel parent par
un groupe d'intégristes et suite à
l'attaqué dont a été victime hélène
delavault bouffes du nord
ça va vous falloir une interview 12 août
on va commencer par des gi monseigneur
lefebvre lefebvre c'est marrant on a
l'impression que tout au tout tourne
autour de mon chien le faire et en
seront que finalement
tout le monde dit commencé dans le
phèdre évident ah ouais il est largué
les vieux quoi il est vieux tout le
monde attend qu'ils cas samir et qui va
qui va leur et qu'il le remplaçait quand
il va casser cela mythe comme se dit
c'est ça un peu le trac c'est tout le
monde 22 ans l'abbé laguérie la ville a
guéri c'est un des héritiers potentiels
dont il a fait beaucoup parler de lui
surtout à l'époque du détail jean marie
le pen
pourquoi parce qu'ils étaient d'accord
lui oui il était d'accord
il faut dire quelque chose c'est que à
chaque fois qu'on a parlé avec des
intégristes de la seconde guerre
mondiale par exemple pour eux l'épisode
le plus horrible de la seconde guerre
mondiale c'est en gros ce qui s'est
passé à la libération
ouais c'est l'épuration chacun silence
comme ça pour eux ils ont un peu
l'attitude disons neutraliste c'est à
dire que c'est un peu l'attitude de
francs côtes salazar
il m'a vraiment notre liste
ils ont une certaine tendresse pour le
maréchal pétain alors dont gérard c'est
un personnage étonnant parce que un jour
donc vous occuper de lui puis vous voyez
débarquer mobutu et dont on sait qu'il a
fait remplacer les non-chrétiens des
habitants du congo par des non africains
et finalement il fait le voyage il va
dans le sait dans le midi qui est
installé dans gerland tout près du mont
ventoux
ouais alors dont gérard c'est un peu le
walt disney de l'intégrisme il est en
train de faire construire deux immenses
couvent en style néo roman on est en
plein dans le passé et il a une
cinquantaine de moines
on nous a précisé que beaucoup étaient
d'anciens saint cyrien effectivement
sont des moines soldats les nouveaux
croisés lab et nantes parce qu'on va
toujours des toujours des affiches dans
les rues avec des labels nantais sait
qui c'est habite nantes
ce quelqu'un pour le situer un peu une
de ses positions les plus hard
ça a été de dire qu'ils refusaient de
défiler contre l'avortement parce que
les manifestations contre l'avortement
se faisait au nom de la liberté met
d'accord et que pour lui la liberté
c'est le désordre
l'autre chose amusante et il l'avait
prévu la fin du monde pour 83 il s'est
planté on est toujours là on est
toujours là
romain marie alias bernard antony il
faut quand même préciser il a été sur
les listes de le pen pour les élections
européennes et qu'il est très proches du
front national est en ce moment le
torchon brûle un peu entre les
intégristes et le thème je crois dire je
vais utiliser nos photos pour la
campagne pourquoi le torchon brûle entre
les intégristes et le pen moi j'ai une
petite que oui j'ai une petite théorie
c'est que le pen aime beaucoup se faire
prendre en photo à côté du pape
ouais alors si suis monseigneur lefebvre
jusqu'au bout
finies les photos avec le pain dans la
famille a justement parce que c'est dans
la famille à nos vous taisez le nom
c'est pas dans cette famille on vous
explique finalement si jean paul ii a pu
sortir de pologne
c'est parce qu'en fait c'est un agent du
kgb il appelle l'autre oui les intégrer
ce vivent un peu dans le dans la hantise
du complot ou alors il ya deux grands
complots un complot
massoni des francs maçons et un complot
communiste et on nous a donc expliqué ce
qui revient très souvent dans les
discussions que si les russes ont laissé
sortir jean paul 2 pologne c'est
forcément que c'est un agent a eu donc
jean paul du communisme le compte de
reee commencé sur guitar perez à
l'enquêté je sais pas où tu étais parti
il a dit à un bar bio didon grimbert il
a un drôle de nom là quand même
rappelez moi et pelé moi le maître aminé
toiture il attendait il est allié avec
une famille très juridique sa sécurité
est alors d'un seul coup ça lui a fait
l'arrêt sur elle m'a dit ah bon il est
pas les règles le compte de reee comment
lui c'est celui qui avait qu'on lui a
donnée sainte-clotilde alors lui fait
pas la messe de peace and fait la messe
de deux pôles 6 me oui alors il ya des
nuances qui échappe un peu aux profanes
c'est à dire le compte de reee comme on
nous a dit lui-même que même des gens
très éclairé en cette matière s'est elle
trompée avec rie la messe de paul 6 pour
la messe oui il fait la messe de paul si
c'est ça passe très bien
c'est vrai que c'est une question de
génuflexions en plus ou en moins
disons que françois brigneau comme il le
dit lui-même d'ailleurs
et toute cette mouvance autour d'eux se
situe dans ce qu'ils appellent la
tendance nationale catholique
non je ne sais pas si ça vaut quelque
chose mais national catholic euh ouais
pas loin d'autres choses et pierre sidos
inodore ça ça me rappelle ma jeunesse au
quartier latin
pierre sidos maintenant est devenu
vraiment un national catholic d'ailleurs
au meeting de l'antique à powell 9
il se faisait présenté comme le fils
d'un ministre du maréchal mais c'est
vrai ça bah si le 10 secondes alors
merci dos maintenant me lis peu avec des
skins de des hells angels pour le
national qu'apple ici justement est un
personnage dans votre article assez
étonnant c'est yvon le le tattoo est là
parce que ce qu'est ce qui est terrible
c'est que maintenant on voit des hells
avec des avec des harley et puis qui ont
des coeurs chouan sur la boisserie c'est
simple dit ouais
on leur dégaine et tout ça c'est un
quelque chose qui sort un petit peu côté
cowboy et
c'est une récupération du cow-boy à la
française le chevalier rogerie que les
cowboys si à nice a fondé révérence en
ouvrant la porte aux filles
ouais vous avez en votre et jacques
dufilho en faisant votre enquête aussi
où il très curieux alors jacques dufilho
je savais déjà qu'il définissait comme
un paysan ouais mais c'est un paysan
faisant la définir comme un paysan soit
c'est pas non mais enfin j'ai
l'impression qu'ils passent quand même
plus de temps sur les planches que
marchand mais c'est un paysan qui a fait
aussi saumur donc toute cette tradition
française
alors ce que j'ai retenu surtout chez
jacques dufilho c'est que lui n'aime pas
beaucoup les orléans nous a même
carrément dit les orléans ce sont des
assassins
il ya un truc est très étonnant dans
votre papier c'est qu'il y en a qui vous
soutiennent que jésus-christ n'étaient
pas juifs par exemple parce qu'ils ont
du mal à admettre
en tant que catholique que jésus-christ
et tuer des juifs
oui c'est ça commencer tout de suite
quand j'ai eu des conversations devant
le cinéma saint michel qui avait brûlé
il ya deux intégristes comme ça qu'ils
m'avaient repérée qui m'ont dit et si on
faisait un film sur abraham
ouais en train de faire des cochonneries
son entourage alors je leur disais vous
savez dans la bible il se passe des tas
de choses leur libre regarder le roi
salomon etc
je leur disais mais vous savez jésus
délaissant de david et salomon et m'ont
dit non à bras du tout donc quand jean
paul ii visite une synagogue pour eux
c'est parce que c'est un agent du kgb
quoi ah oui absolument pour eux tout ce
qui n'est pas strictement catholique
apostolique et romain et banni mais
alors ce qui est curieux c'est justement
monseigneur lefebvre effet un schisme au
nom de sa fidélité à l'église
enfin c'est des contradictions avec
lesquels ils ont l'air doit avoir fait
un papier uniquement sur le label voyage
en intégrer mais pourquoi uniquement sur
les intégristes disons catholique parce
que les intégristes juifs qui a new york
par exemple refuse l'état d'israël parce
que ça m'a sont pas d'accord ou même
dans certains quartiers à paris ou même
en france les intégristes musulmans
pourquoi seulement sont sans prendre
fallait quand même déjà allé à new york
où
mais je n'ai pas eu envie de faire un
papier sur l'intégrisme en général parce
que l'intégrisme j'attends quelque chose
qui est propre à l'heure d'évoquer tout
à l'heure à 89 c'est que 89 ça l'intérêt
de catalyser à la fois les spirituels
disons genre lefebvre et des vieux
briscards de l'extrême droite qui
reviennent et qui retrouve une nouvelle
jeunesse
je vais dire que l'intégrisme tels
qu'ils se présentent maintenant c'est
quelque chose de typiquement france il
ya un intégrisme protestants comme aux
états unis mais ils sont presque car
rapide il ya un intégrisme juifs on a vu
ça aux dernières élections israéliennes
mais je crois qu'en france l'intéresse
pas catholique c'est quelque chose que
qu'on sous estime qui risque
sérieusement de faire parler de lui
sortie de l'enquète vous pensez qu'un
vrai danger troisième single extrait de
l'album labyrinthes bonne anniversaire
bonne année bananier tout-va ziggles
pâtit
[Musique]
magna
et la relève
paris15 paris s'en va
[Musique]
alors
non
3 genou
[Musique]
puis comme les coups bas travaillent à
londres
leurs banques
[Musique]
car sa lettre
non
à
à l'aller
oh
aho
et
santé
retournez au lac
et
[Musique]
non
ouais
[Musique]
un pitch aux à dimanche 22 janvier hôtel
intercontinental derniers préparatifs
pour la collection haute couture
printemps-été 89
christian lacroix mado pas tous tommy
piatti me piatti fatso finita décès bush
père op lawson kodjo vite solo quan
d'hôtel et d'auto t min et mado pour
tout aussi à mon actif en amont et faty
fort ce qu'il hausse à 10,1 avec élites
politiques aiello tiennent de l'homme et
basterra quêtes ou celui d'enfants et
sont vite on me calmer dans capriccio
than la solitude et aucouturier au
moment là autres geeks aux mânes à cause
hadayamet puis aux frais tiozzo et des
tropiques ont encore des amendes et
capriccio sa maladie était belle la
seconde à noah khadija et l'accès
[Musique]
ce qu'on entend c'est marino marini
capriccio ça pour ceux qui le savent on
dit marc bureau et little italy lots
permis basquiat keith ou celui d'enfants
elles sont vite on me parle
tu as pris tshosane kulhavy et très
carnaval c'est aux banques aura lieu le
carnaval le bouquet final de la
collection christian lacroix avec la
cèze n'est question là
florent pagny en face vanessa paradis à
gauche mais en moins les voix libye je
la bonne
j'aime d'être françoise lacroix farid
chopel philippe corti margaux hemingway
rené gillet la barre mais on passe aux
news à la grande halle de la villette
jusqu'au 4 février le coq de régine
chopinot costume je laissais jean paul
gaultier alors que great balls of fire
le film sur sa vie est en cours de
tournage
jerry lee lewis est inculpé pour la
septième fois 22 créanciers lui
réclament plus de 3 millions de dollars
d'impayés
bon courage au bâton avec un tel client
c
bravo monsieur carnaval changement de
pipe avec enter h à l'elysée montmartre
le top 50 ne passera pas par nous qu'ils
disent et ça baigne pour la bande à
poissons ce que vous entendez c'est le
rap dérape tous leurs tubes 86,17
conditionné
même ici
le night club et sylvain bergère c'est
aussi l'agencé france presse
150 bureaux dans le monde 5000 employés
travaillant en six langues pour diffuser
un million de mots par jour et par nuit
[Musique]
ça c'est west amber de passe
le final qui sauf l'homme de survivantes
commun teens le troisième s'appelait
oliver ne s'est pas suite à éradiquer
c
louis jam on dit jamin gamin on pourrait
dire james p comme ya deux mondes hijab
oui
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
tuez pas de photographes c'est quand on
travaille ça consiste à faire des
photographies ensuite à retravailler
par-dessus pas exactement par dessus un
parfum de parts de suspens avant
beaucoup avant quand tu fais un décor tu
photographies des gens devant le décor
dans le décor dans le décor et après tu
retravaille la photo marie de
retravailler par dessus c'est à dire
c'est une série d'étapes différentes qui
passe de la peinture à la prise de vue à
la photographie au tirage de laboratoire
des étapes finales des choses finalement
très classique mais tu t'écoutes eu
d'effort landon qui se disent plutôt par
transfert soit pas vraiment du collage
c'est plutôt des choses qui se disent
pas transparente c'est une peinture
cette peinture a ensuite aidé centre et
sert de décor
ensuite ces gens qui cette quantité de
gens que je photographie dans la rue me
sert ensuite pour redessiner ou au
travail au laboratoire et finalement
toutes ces étapes s'arrête un moment
donné mais c'est un peu ça s'arrête à un
moment ça s'arrête ou des pas vraiment
non plus puisque après les gens voient
les gens que tu fais des fois des
sérigraphies à partir de ça mais oui ça
arrive voilà par exemple il a été
influencé par qui sont multiples
influences
j'aime beaucoup pour tous mais dies pour
dessiner max ernst
on fait des collages du bricolage etc
non mais moi je ne suis pas très pour le
mot collage pas ce qui concerne mon
travail c'est pas vraiment décollage
n'est pas particulière avoir un accès
quand tu travailles chez toi tu écoutes
moi comme musique
ouais c'est très variable
c'est franck des années soixante dix à
la musique plein gré je sais pas ça va
des doors satire extrêmes
musique classique aussi s'est pas
apaisée pas un goût particulier j'ai pas
le musicien ça vous convient aujourd'hui
une peinture photographie de louis jam
servi entre 5000 francs demandés tout
petit dans les petites photographie à
tarente ronde prend pour exemple là où
il en est bien sorti sais que c'est dur
de vendre des photos parce que non mais
c'est pas des originaux qu'on vend ce
sera un moment des tirages serré comme
tueur travail par dessus ça leur donne
une pas vraiment un art travaille pas
nécessairement deuxième est en tout cas
si je travaille dessus c'est pas pour
leur donner une valeur par la lumière et
pour rejoindre le même principe que la
peinture je crois qu'il ya beaucoup
d'artistes qui ont déjà travaillé sur le
phénomène de reproduction vont
constituer les puces et les warhol les
choses comme ça l est les plus proches
je crois qu'effectivement le marché
encore les problèmes avec ça je crois
que d habitude
maintenant va l'acheter de la peinture
et donc on a plus de chances d'être
connu plus vite si on est peintre que si
on fait de l'art avec autre chose mais
on est
à terme je pense qu'ils se passent
beaucoup d'autres choses que la peinture
en ce moment et qui a beaucoup de moyens
comme ça qui arrive un peu à maturité et
la porte aux la vidéo alors au début tu
tues baigné dès souvent des peintres en
pâture photographier et elle est souvent
des fans tu as fait jean michel basquiat
tafer garrouste a fait dire aux a fait
fait boiron dont tu as fait tes copains
commencé comme ça fait quelque chose de
très beau sur wii ça a commencé avec des
proches comme ça les gens mais alors là
par contre tu es parti à faire des
arabes à barbès d
raconte pourquoi tu es passé de ils ont
des pipolo aux anonymes
je crois qu'ils ont quelque chose en
commun c'est que c'est c'est l'extérieur
pour moi c'est à dire quand je fais la
peinture quand je suis dans mon
laboratoire aller voter les photos je
montre dans la situation d'un artiste
d'un peintre quoi ce que je suis tout
seul ces solitaires comme pratique la
photographie de me permet de m'ouvrir
totalement sûr sur extérieur de me
nourrir de tout cet aîné réponds moi
s'il s'est élargie ont quand même de
placer comme ça des gens connus des gens
de tous milieux
ouais vidal et commencer à mettre ton
des corps dans la rue c'est pareil ça
change a l'air de votants ça reste quand
même et même le même prédit même à ma
porte
moi j'apporte à peu près les mêmes
choses évidemment ce qui est très
différent c'est les histoires de
conscience et tout ça c'est que les gens
dans la peinture sont des gentils par
métier contrôler leur image
moi j'en ai terminé comme sac revenu sur
de provocateur par jour à leurs propres
à limoges les gens dans la rue c'est
différent c'est peut-être plus sérieux
parce que c'est des gens qui sont
totalement inconscients de ce qu'on peut
en faire ensuite quoi donc c'est une
image comme ça que je que je prends la
parole kim à prendre oui ce sont
sûrement c'est de se mettre en place et
de plus personnel en tout cas c'est une
suite ou que tu as nécessaire on peut
voir en ce moment quand on travaille au
musée d'art moderne de la ville de paris
oui c'était la vache qui rit denis
allard
recruté que c'est jusqu'à quand je
combats de mars non je crois tu sais pas
et s'il fallait lui je sais pas si tu
devais rester toi une définition dans le
dictionnaire dépeindre ce serait quoi
d'où les diables déjà c'est en
pratiquant la photographie si je
pourrais être dans les dictionnaires des
peines serait pas mal serait pas loin
d'être parmi les premiers mais ya quand
même pas mal de gens qui ont fait les
choses très sérieuses et qui maintenant
sont un peu reconnus de la photographie
ça sert à quoi la peinture pour toi et
moi je me bats pour moi ça me serre
personnellement en tant qu'artiste façon
très personnelle mais je pense que ça ne
doit servir à rien en face à serra peine
chose c'est à faire de l'argent ça sert
à faire vivre les gens c'est tout un
milieu mais en soit je crois que ça tout
ça c'est un peu
ces effets secondaires procès les
charmes de la vie ce qui sert à rien
ouais c'est sûr cher en fait en tout cas
pour la peinture je crois que c'est
essentiel que ça serve à rien on vous
l'a gardée pour la bonne bouche voici
celui que toute la presse anglaise a
surnommé tranche de patates
quand on le voit on se demande pas
pourquoi du tout habituée aux reprises
et disco queen style de nas main thelma
houston ou gloria gaynor
le small town bay commune a répondu à
l'appel de eric des remontées pour
enregistrer avec six autres artistes
33,2 uno courage tranche de patates
c'est un peu mieux que d'habitude
oh
[Musique]
chatel
e
[Musique]
te
m
à
[Musique]
et
nous
[Musique]
m
c'est
[Musique]
oui
on le suit
[Musique]
c
salut bande de nazes et n'oubliez pas
pour les yeux rouges les lunettes noires
et axa devrait maintenant je t'aime
quand même fou manor
[Musique]
on va
oui où
bah
mais
quoi
pour les hommes
oh
moi
[Musique]
oui
à
[Musique]
oui
bah
pour les hommes
wade
moi
[Musique]
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater de
dinars 10 tubes abonnez vous y mettez un
peu de bleu